whoo hi we're back for another exciting
episode of day pals all right um that
was good that was a good amount of
enthusiasm I feel I feel really good
about that
there's no music so we make our music
good thing we can sing and dance I'm
Kate Quigley and this is a very fun
episode because it's Girl Talk which are
my favourite episodes when we just have
girls on and as usual I have on a good
friend who knows too much about my love
life and will probably give away
information that I don't care to share
Ariel kishan Chi thank you for being
here having me I guess I'm gonna have to
zip it no you can say anything I don't
care the last episode I had on a guy
that I went on a date with and I had on
my friend and my friend proceeded to ask
details about our dates and like how far
we hooked up and like what happened
stuff that I wasn't even planning to
like talk about did he give you all the
details did he like nothing nothing
happened we just kissed she was like did
you kiss with tongue did he touch your
boob oh my Carrie seriously am i calm
down we went on two dates like it wasn't
that serious
uh anyway but Ariel is a very funny
comedian and you can take it check out
her web series don't be [ __ ] and follow
her on twitter at iranian mermaid and
instagram at Ariel's not a mermaid and I
am very excited about my other guest
today cuz girl I see you out all the
time and we always talk and we always be
us but we never really got to hang out
and kick it
I know and you're hilarious you're very
funny comedian also funny actress we
used to work together on sketches at a
place at a place called all deaf digital
yeah
precious as can we talk about we talk
about measures is banned from and we're
gonna get into that why this [ __ ] is
banned she's bad as [ __ ] precious halt
everyone hey
at one precious comedy yeah you're bad
this is okay so I met precious at all
deaf digital which for those who don't
know you should follow them
because they make funny [ __ ] it's
Russell Simmons Digital Network right uh
funny stuff aerials worked there before
as well so I met you there yeah we work
together yeah I think I'm like what are
those like booty grab challenge maybe a
kissing one there's no oh did you do
that what the black and white guy at
first time yeah oh yeah I did the white
girl you know it's so funny I did white
girls kiss black guys for the first time
and have all the [ __ ] that I've done
it's not your first time kissing a black
it was acting yeah but it was my first
time kissing slink Johnson jeez I don't
get it like Jesus he and that's what's
so funny is all the [ __ ] that I've done
I only ever get recognized for their hey
you're the one that made out like Jesus
yeah but that's a good guy the kids if
you're gonna kiss appreciate a nice lips
yeah yeah very tall very I just stand
out of box to eat you
he's like seven would you rather and be
short no no I would rather stand on a
box you know I have to squat down right
yeah that's true I just like I found out
do you ever realize like what the
perfect sex height is for you before did
no no I never figured I just I think
that 3 2 is the perfect height for me
wait yours is 6-3 6-3 either might
depend on their torso length I guess
yeah how tall are you
I'm 5/8 see for me at 6 - and I'm only 5
5 so maybe it's your [ __ ] eye guy I'm
[ __ ] his about 6 - oh yeah you know
and is it a good it's a good eye you
know I wasn't right like I I wasn't
thinking about her like I'm not thinking
about that guy that's been like the [ __ ]
dudes I'm like oh and that yeah yeah
when thinking about that's true I've
been at you're right the best sex I ever
had was what the guy who's my pretty
much my I'm like a little guy
whip out some shitty below did you know
he's always met you I'm a kid oh sure
you hooked up with me hey but he'd hear
good things about time I heard good
things too Tony just so you know Tony
Tony do you know Tony's really he's a
bunny in there yeah he's very funny he
was he's on Last Comic Standing I think
yes come here or maybe a GT I don't know
one of the yeah he did really want very
very fun uh but uh yeah no but what I
meant about the height thing is like
sort of guys when they cuddle you oh you
tell my cuddly well I'm talking about
you really you have a thing no I don't
like I don't know that's not where he's
going can we just talk about this but
this is important just talk about what
you suck you know hard lean fat no I'm
telling you though then they [ __ ] you
from the back during the cuddle I like a
guy I like a guy to be the right height
so when we spoon his dick is right there
I mean honestly there's no height
requirement you just have to the right
shape
I bet you were talking about different
positions she's a [ __ ] is only when
you lay down which is a [ __ ] and his
dick is down there I'm at his hannel be
in your baguette family I'm loving
someone get Brad boys on the phone we
need to have Brad come over and spoon
spoon for real do you don't like that we
know I should know this about you
because you know Utama
come on we're gonna talk about dates and
date village you know what I didn't even
go on a date times like 27 oh yeah you
today where are you from we tell you had
sex me well you know we're from the date
is like [ __ ] you smoke all day your
smoke mean wait a minute wait a minute
worried frog of course do you gotta eat
you got he doesn't require me but I'm
saying like is just like where are you
from Texas Dallas Dallas Cowboys to
anyone leading the division I'm so happy
for my team cuz I was a fan when we were
losing you know saying so really wait
here's a very hot Dallas Cowboys player
who followed me mr. Graham and I almost
[ __ ] my pads because I'm not a Dallas
Cowboys fan I'm not gonna lie I'm sorry
I'm not I'm not tagged nice meeting you
yeah but I am a fan of this guy he's hot
as [ __ ] and when he's away it's ah we're
not
it's nothing has ever happened he just
followed me and like we DM for like one
second and then that was that that was
it buddy send you a dick face
no no yes for one no no he's nice and
you know I don't want to go there I'm
not gonna ask him for a dick pic border
I don't know how you did it to a nun
when you walk around in bikinis vote me
she anything winner like that no I'm
saying I would rather wait and like
maybe see it in person okay I mean I
guess sure well I I would date him not
his name his name is guy that's really
good at football not telling his name I
can't you know why I can't say I won't
you even bring the data wrong with I'll
tell you why I can't say his name on
here cuz here's what happens
I [ __ ] talked about playing tennis
with Jon Lovitz on here and for the next
six months everybody on my Twitter was
tweeting at me and Jon Lovitz like are
you guys banging you guys did and I'm
then I had to explain to Jon Lovitz what
happened
now I don't do that anymore so I can't
say that his name is he hey there's a
good wood that's a great way he's
already here's the [ __ ] he's a [ __ ]
break it renders he everything and he
has beautiful lips and he's a
great-looking black piece of chocolate
evening like sunlight he's very hot but
I will say that if you're watching or
listening Zeke you yes you're very hot
but you know that only goes so far
and same with money and football but we
should go out yeah our hero shows he
seems like a nice guy at all
does he cuddle yeah that's a good
question you know yeah he cuddles I
could tell yeah look I don't need a good
I need a cuddle
I only want to cuddle you if we're
dating what I love with you in this day
I don't really care about cuddling
touching me after sex I'm like can you
just leave yeah talking you don't want
to cuddle ever no not if I'm with you
then I would cut it so I mean if you're
with it that's what I mean when I say if
we're dating
if we're casually Rocking you're dating
somebody just cuddling naturally happens
no nothing you don't have to like
schedule it you don't have to be like
from I don't side Joanne it's 5:45 we're
gonna remodel we're gonna cuddle I want
to be in this position I don't schedule
cuddling but what I'm saying you caught
it would be but did you man I only cut a
look if I'm spending the night at your
house okay that means we're dating to
the point where I feel like it's a thing
right I don't sleep over with guys I'm
casually seeing or like just kind of
hooking up with and that makes sense
because I know what a question came up
on the show that I do about like in the
morning if like a guy jumps up like
before morning sings like you ready to
help morning six and he gets up and goes
and brush his teeth all right
yeah get up and go take a shower Oh like
he's interrupting the morning so yeah
you know that's what she was saying like
how do you feel about that I'm like well
clearly
he's not comfortable with you like you
nothing he wants you to get her to leave
he should have left last night yeah if
you can't roll over just roll in his
[ __ ] you know Xena noise that's right
if we are talking about night a cuddle
that's why I need the right height for
the car but I think if you're spending
the night together you should be able
you should be comfortable in number just
IV yeah kick them out that would mess up
my whole like [ __ ] just forget it you
blew it can I just say why why did I
sleep next to you all night this is why
I don't have guys at my orange I'm just
kiddin
this is why I don't have guys getting a
reward this is why I don't have guys at
my place ever I go to their place
because then I can decide when I leave
and if I want to stay out I have decide
when you leave from other like you know
I can tell you when to leave [ __ ] like
it don't like a genius
she you know why else I don't have guys
at my place though and I was thinking
about this yesterday I need help with
this Ariel this might be a project for
us I need a better I don't have a good
sex bed my bed it makes a lot of noise
and it moves around its got like a iron
it's great for being tied up in bed yeah
yeah I need a different bed so what you
know what that bed probably would play
good to a guy's ego you know like it
really swear I am killing it [ __ ] so
like you read it you know you make sound
effect yeah so I should only let the
guys I really like cocaine
you feel real being gonna stir you know
our guys really want you to do is jack
him off all day just stroke him just
make him feel good
she's no like it's like when you have to
it's like when you fake choke like I
always fake choke you know on it it's
very small what gotta make him feel like
it's big guys you're the king Larry is
the duly noted
so gonna do you got a choke on it right
in Erin shaker said no my producers like
can I leave is there a way to get out of
this conversation yeah I mean Arielle
just yells you're the king that's always
a when I really do that I don't make
sound effects and I'll be like oh that
was good you know that's how you'll be
like oh that was good oh that was good
well done sir I will give you a great
job go star okay I need you to leave
good oh so precious are you single right
now I am single
okay so so wait a second you said when
you're in Texas you didn't date you
didn't start dating till you were 27
what do you know know what you know hate
it I know I want y'all Carly I mean you
know he's dating but it's really coming
just like I mean I just more hung out
you know like I hung out I didn't really
they weren't your boyfriend they weren't
my boyfriend's they're like our friends
so the guys did where my boyfriend's you
know did we did the dating [ __ ] and I
whoa whoa but it still was only like
going out to eat movies boring [ __ ] like
now I want to be adventurous like I
would say want to be I want you to be
creative you know what I'm saying like
Sam I really have a good day till I
dated a white guy he was the [ __ ] really
really did I it was different kakie what
is your friend
yeah tell us about this this is fast I'm
like really
cuz I really did it like I meant I used
to work at the casino when I met a guy
and he was like the [ __ ] and like what
did he do
I mean look oh he's a producer - oh I'm
like a television because you watch
everybody's [ __ ] towns a producer
like your Starbucks baristas like and
also I'm a producer
so okay you met him working what cuz but
he was just nothing you know what and
this is when I didn't know I was a real
comedian the bicycle casino you know I'm
saying like I don't know what was the
comedian I was way in the casino or not
bicycle casino what is that you ever
heard of the bicycle casino I've heard
the name
it's the bicycle as a Hawaiian Gardens
it's crystal Park I worked at all of
them it's oh it sounds it's like she and
I was like off the 405 yeah coast of
bills okay all right yeah but anyway
what was your first day like with him
where did he take you
Yamashiro tell us first it's Yamashiro
he sings on time for hele you know it's
cute and he know the history about it
it's either on the first date yeah you
like that I loved it was so sweet and
you know my country and [ __ ] like oh
she's not like a mom but he was there he
was he was the [ __ ] nanny owned a store
he went we went to his store he like
opened up the story was closed and so we
chilled around the store and he showed
me like Oh what kind of store it looks
means yeah I mean it's clothing like
look at jobs like I think like I never
heard of you see I'm impressed he's like
Richard Gere from pretty ones and Annie
took me to like an authentic Indian food
and then a Japanese enzyme bath like we
did just weird [ __ ] like that was fun
and I had never done before I mean and
we still cool now you know but what
happened to him why didn't you stay with
that guy I mean I never even had sex
with him II didn't even kiss me to the
third day are you serious you like that
I like that yeah that I had maybe like
me I was shocked like damn I don't
that's about you did you see that oh you
thought he was just taking you out on
all these days that he was like a little
coal country [ __ ] hey allergies pretty
cool or low country I get weirded out if
I got this is like so funny I just said
this to a guy the other day I get so
many guys that like try to
hyper-sexualized me and like make a move
so [ __ ] fast just cuz my Instagram is
like what you're saying like you're in a
bikini all the time like why would why
wouldn't that but that's not that's not
how I really am oh but then what happens
is if it gets too long and they don't
try I think I start to get really
insecure cuz I'm so used to guys trying
to bang me so fast that I start to be
like you know one of the
why doesn't this gonna [ __ ] Matt just
want to be friends no no God is gonna
like take you out great guy I know
straight guys gonna take you out and
spend money on you like make it ever
unless he's really into I think what it
is is like they want to get to know you
as a person
yeah so sweet so nice no it's like oh oh
my god thank you you think I'm a human
you think there's a point where it goes
where if you go to many dates without
the kiss they get put into the friend
zone
at some point like how how many dates do
you think it's okay I see that's the
thing it's not an amount of dates like
it's the chemistry within the date like
do I like you do I vibe with you do you
make me want to go be a better comedian
and a better person and do you motivate
my life like I feel like I've been
closer to like my guy friend than the
guy was [ __ ] just because of our
conversations you know I'm saying like
yeah we've really connect like we're we
you but you're not you nosy I have that
was front like my friend Jackson you
know Jackson McQueen calm okay I thought
you guys were friends
Jackson's [ __ ] might wanna buy my
closest friends he knows everything
about me inside now I mean like and we
have great chemistry we have great
comedic timing and everything but I
don't think I mean he's like my friend
we've never gonna say but like he has a
family and we will win isn't it like no
it's just like I mean I see what you're
saying cuz I'm so close to him and then
sometimes in my head I'm like and I
think he's hot but I never have the
impulse to like make a move hook up but
you know what those are the type of
relationships that even if you do hook
up that'll still be your friend because
that that friendship and that chemistry
is there like you can't like if you
always like fail it runs yeah it runs
deeper than so much bigger than it
worries I usually [ __ ] with guys who I
know I can be like alright I'm sick of
you ain't [ __ ] with you no more
intense you know or [ __ ] you your mama
who cares you know but when you really
care about some man you know one you
don't want to miss that up you know yeah
it's true I think that's why I'm afraid
though of like like I would be terrified
to hook up with him because I be afraid
of messing that up so I wouldn't because
I feel free and and you love them so you
wouldn't want to [ __ ] it up yeah you
wouldn't do horrible things to him like
you wouldn't go psycho on him I don't do
that
they're sound like a lot I don't do that
I don't know what you're talking about
all right I've only had my neighbor you
already found them and you still want
all these [ __ ] dates and counting on
me [ __ ] for nothing counting up so what
your date should we kiss yeah we
wouldn't definitely be on day two it
doesn't happen by date - yes he's not in
he is not in pity I can't help it if I
don't feel a sexual connection with a
guy really quickly I I never get it it
doesn't come later to me no you know off
top if you're gonna [ __ ] yeah now now so
if you're going out on dates and you
know you're not gonna [ __ ] him you're
being nice and we're too old to be nice
now goddamn it now I know when I look at
you you are [ __ ] am I gonna invest
the time and playing like I don't want
to [ __ ] well or am I gonna gonna [ __ ]
you are we gonna be cool what am I gonna
do with this potential [ __ ] cuz I will
[ __ ] you you know you always yeah you
always know you could like beat a guy
that you're like about and then like him
he says turns you on
like the first date or two yeah but but
and you can also be totally turned on by
someone and not [ __ ] them for a while
because you want to like know if you
really like them or if you're just like
[ __ ] him I almost married someone
just because we had such good sexual
chemistry but we hated each other sounds
familiar
yeah hated each other like we would like
get in these fights that were just nasty
but then we would like have amazing sex
like am i bad yeah hate sex is the best
yeah when I get so angry at there's
there's like there's been two guys only
two guys that make me so [ __ ] angry
like crazy that I like I see oh my god
I'm the psycho girl I am like the one
blowing up their phone and like wanting
to show up and like TP the [ __ ] like
egg their car and just like bad [ __ ] but
the more they make me mad the more I'm
like oh okay that's sex boy it's hard to
find good sexual chemistry so once you
find it is it harder for girls though
because I always feel like with those
guys like they're like yeah the sex is
great but that's not like those guys
have an easier
I'm walking away from the section and I
do um I I think that you in your case I
think this is like an isolated lay your
[ __ ] up like we could control our
emotions
yeah we're here me yeah so I think we
all have those emotions but I think
being an adult you know you realize what
situations are you take them for what
they are and you don't yeah or do you
think that for guys it's easier to give
up a amazing set like guys won't stay in
something super toxic just for the sex
as long as girls will I don't think some
guys do you've heard about those guys
who are like yeah she's crazy she's
always talking me but they also like it
because they like that they bring out
the crazy and the girl you know those
guys who only date crazy women but
always complain about it that's what
these some guys that like it cuz it
really does make them feel good about
themselves but I have to say that we
have higher standards for what's
considered good sex than they true true
you know yeah it's like what makes a guy
great in bed to you to me I mean I think
it's just like money just kidding no
orgasm if you if you Hey because I think
you know guys gonna win every time I
don't know when less your pussy's Church
you know guys win every time they're
gonna get their rocks off but you know
like I think women don't really
understand and they're out here having
kids and doing all this [ __ ] and
something I'll have never do that a real
orgasm where the bed is [ __ ] up where
you have to wash the sheets in like yeah
you know like that is the experience
that a woman is supposed to have during
sex not just laying there like it he
said it was good or I was he said some
ways in this [ __ ] in and taller you
know like no like they were supposed to
be you know like no we don't want it
like a guy but there if there is
supposed to sometimes you do yeah
hand down and he don't let you move but
no um it is supposed to be a great
experience a lot of people haven't
experienced it and they're just being
nice out here I only care about myself
exactly can we talk about your move
oh my signature move calls it her
signature move okay
Arielle and I are so different all right
I have a guy friend who's all the time
I just want to can I just eat your [ __ ]
I don't eat your [ __ ] I don't need to
[ __ ] you I just want to eat your [ __ ]
and I'm always like no because if you do
I'll feel guilty I'll feel like I owe
you then I'll have to [ __ ] you and I
don't want to [ __ ] you so I say no
meanwhile I'm telling Ariel this story
and she's like pull the signature move
like what's that so I actually don't
have a problem getting an orgasm
it happens like I'm like a
twelve-year-old boy like it's just like
boom and then and then but then it
happens and then I lose interest and I'm
like oh [ __ ]
you have to pretend to care about you
now and and soda signature move is my
signature move is I get on top handle my
business and then when I'm done I'm like
oh my god you know what I'm really tired
hilarious you just take care of yourself
like but not here like go home and
cheers to yourself but not here and you
go home and get in your car sorry
like I mean like more like always
hilarious like I'm like I'm like I'm
like your work here is done I could
never do it I would feel so I avow feel
so guilty I need to stop if I care about
oh and I couldn't do it it's good [ __ ]
up 35 am I getting on top of lazy [ __ ]
don't belong on the way to this
[ __ ] okay no dick is gonna
impress me enough to do nothing no
trying on nothing it's some compromised
[ __ ] okay we're [ __ ] from the side
when you are when you smoke you get lazy
well I smoke all the time so I do get
creative as well you know this we hated
Lee lady she finds new ways to be
laziest what happened I'm just saying
when it comes to say I'm lazy in bed I'm
not like the one who's just gonna jump
on you I got I don't just jump on them
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm tired miles and I
know if I'm if I'm excited about you
catch me on a good night blessing it was
a present have you ever seen I think
it's Daniel Tosh I can't Roberts Tosh or
Justin I think I saw shoes has a bit
about basically how when I got like
girls always want to [ __ ] but when
you're in a relationship that girls
wouldn't have sex more than guys and
basically he says that's because the
first time a guy [ __ ] you for him is
the best time it's so exciting and after
that every time after it gets just a
little less aggressive and so it's not
that they're not that into it anymore
but you know for the girl it's not
necessarily the other way around it's
like you know he loves you more and more
every time and [ __ ] and meanwhile you're
like I've had this [ __ ] I want some
nubes yeah but lately I've been feeling
like a guy in that in that regard cuz
there's been a couple guys I've hooked
up with in the last year that it was so
good the first time just so like just
hot and exciting like fun that I've
never been able to get the guy to [ __ ]
me like that again but cuz they but they
work so hard that first time someone is
you got an approval I show y'all that
moves and
say and then after the first time I feel
like every time they put in slightly
less effort until I'm the one that's
getting bored right right
I mean I don't think the first time is
ever that great like really good but
it's not like like the second and third
time is always when he gets a little
better the second time you know if this
[ __ ] is real or if you was dreaming your
junk junk you're like you can be like
okay I'm gonna do because yeah and then
you know like their body and like he's
gonna do that move or like yeah gonna
happen yeah I got like stomachs I like a
big stump I like took a big belly yeah I
like a big belly I like a big Jason Wynn
type of big really big belly because the
pressure with the belly and you know
when I do get on that is good you know
it helped you know I got it yeah you're
getting help that's so gonna do a good
angle all right big arms I like a guide
as but not like gross not likes body my
legs hey no I like a guy that has big
rib biceps because when they this is now
we're gonna be like to my butt like when
they're on top and their arms are here I
liked it I grabbed their big [ __ ] I love
big arms it makes me feel safe and it's
small I like a big dick yeah that's
right I love when girls are excited it
matter that means your dick is small
that means you're a nice girl who was
out here not hurting guys feelings
therefore you got guys walking around
here thinking there's something when
they're not but that is too big there is
jealousy and I've had it and it's not
fun I like to them I like a nice medium
size dick if I'm being honest if a guy
knows what he's doing with it medium if
he knows that he's his hands in his
mouth that's all that's perfect to me I
did a guy with a really small dick and
he had the nerve to use magnums shadow I
swear to god he was very rich and he
would spend a lot of money on me so it
was like I was like all right
you would make like a big shot like he'd
pull it out and he's like make sure that
I saw and he's very dramatically rip it
open and I was like come on with this me
oh my god I remember in college this guy
out it was older cuz I had to be 19
maybe 20 I don't know but he was older
he had a house and garden you know like
somebody [ __ ] but he was like it you
know like I said spending money and [ __ ]
like what is he doing but he gave me a
bath like I'm like all this [ __ ] he's
doing giving you a bag gave me a bath I
felt like a grown [ __ ] kid look I've
never had a guy give me a paper
mouthwatering I mean and getting me too
bad like he came in and like cleaned you
he came that's what the murderer doesn't
Dexter before those people know we had
all of that and lotion me down and hand
me into bed and then when we started
doing it his dig was so little but I had
to stop him like no you did not
would you say my mama I stopped to him
like good like what I was like stop stop
whoa stop move like my stop move get up
I can't
I don't feel what did you stop feel
nothing if you can't feel it that's a
probably all nothing I love you feel did
you I hooked up with one guy left right
Wow
did he start to cry hey man cry but he
was like written you could see it in his
feelings with her god he's a bad man we
lied to that bars and is and he was
trying to be romantic and [ __ ] but you
know it all initially described this
well he was trying to distract you from
like his little dig little take I am I
am so honestly I'm so nice that I
wouldn't say it no even if his dick is
small make him feel like he's got also
I'll be like you're you have a great
dick it's perfect I don't want to say I
wouldn't [ __ ] him again but I in them
you're gonna say that yeah you are too
[ __ ] happy but I can see if you
stayed and just was quiet cuz I'm not
even doing that cuz like this is just
ridiculous and a [ __ ] grown also it's
an ego thing for me though because I
want them to be like that's the best
[ __ ] I was the best [ __ ] ever and now
feel like that if you tell how great
their dick is and make them think
they're doing a great job guys are all
about
if you make them think they're doing a
great job they write more of you I and
you want a little dick to want more
yes I do not say I'd go back but I like
the feeling of knowing he still wants I
want every ok I got upset didn't
satisfied me
[ __ ] you must die and you have a ghost a
diptych is only barrister [ __ ] out of
you in that itty-bitty dick how dare you
be that nice Kate I'm gonna shoot you I
did not expect that out of you know just
be nice first of all first of all I just
want to say ok that no guy has ever been
like I'll never [ __ ] her again
yeah nobody has that happened to me
really yeah one this guy the guy I've
saved in my phone is know who I'm now
friends with yeah I was because first of
all he said he will never [ __ ] me again
even though we're friends now and even
though sometimes I text him at night
when I'm drunk and horny and I'll be
like can we pull these just [ __ ] one
time it means nothing it's the best XP
with the best sex and he's like no
because I know you can't just [ __ ] me
without it meeting something and I know
you'll catch feelings and then I'll want
to kill you and it's not happening and
he won't [ __ ] me well I mean that's
that's different that's different for
being like your pussy's trash yeah you
know no yeah no that's not he wants to I
know he wants to I slept the catch him
on the right night now making me crazy I
want to [ __ ] him so you know what Dan
was I don't even understand that is the
secret to [ __ ] guys if you withhold dig
if you act like you don't want us if you
act like you like burning desire I have
to [ __ ] him I can't believe he's acting
like you don't want to honestly this guy
he's crazy he's not a good person to
date I'm Way smarter than him like
there's really nothing redeeming about
him honestly
except we have amazing sex and the more
he tells me no I keep trying I mean we
haven't [ __ ] in like two years or
something and I keep trying to find new
avenues because you know is morning but
way to skin a cat let's see let me try
this way
they're like hey um I need a new tire on
my car do you think you could help shop
owner you got some sugar gosh you should
just drug in soup at his apartment but
no clothes on asking for eggs Tommy made
in something like like you baked him a
cookie but it has what's the dick thing
the blue pill viagra my Agora a Viagra
good wait this is horrible a guy was
sitting on this podcast right now being
like well first of all when this [ __ ]
got naked her tits were so small they
were the smallest Excite ever so I was
like I'm sorry I can't
and then he was like I'm gonna roofie
your cookie with like we would be might
have put up with so much throughout the
course of our lives look we can get away
with a little bit of like Ricky lady
talk right I'm gonna put up with all
this [ __ ] [ __ ] y'all yeah my guy was
here well a guy ain't here yeah he's
just us
well there's bears Aaron the producer
horrified but I didn't mean like that
Aaron I mean at the table I know you're
a guy we're not gonna rape you though
okay you're married still still your to
vaporize wife alert um this is why is it
taking a fascinating all right so you
grew up in Texas and and then you moved
to LA when I grew up in Texas I went to
college in Arkansas and then I moved to
LA after college and then you started
dating at 27 it's a joke I mean oh I
thought you were serious it's a joke I
mean I don't care like like Mantic
planned out date was I know what I
didn't really I really go on my first
date or a guy picked me up in a car and
took me on a date until I was like 32 or
something no I mean I got winter date
but it was just like when did I'm alert
the [ __ ] you know the routine [ __ ]
there's like boys yeah like an awesome
super fun date that's not dinner drinks
movie
Oh awesome for me would be like some
little kitchen you know I'm a convenient
you we're comedians I like to do fun
[ __ ] if we go bumper car ride
I would have so much [ __ ] fun things
like bowling could be but I love but a
shooting pool like just some shooting
pool is hot I love shooting and I like
lying work oh I have never busy about
headlining screams oh my adventures guys
don't get that we just they don't have
to take I think they have to take you to
a fancy restaurant I would love for when
the state affair was going on or the
County Fair the laki
I wanted a guy to take me to the fair
and win me a stuffed animal like a
little kid now that that is stuffed it's
like you'll remember not just what you
eat I eat every day yeah like let's get
creative with that [ __ ] I'm sorry about
of like a cool different restaurant
something you know I'm trying different
stuff like a radiator yeah yeah just a
weird yeah crazy stuff guys are like
dangerous [ __ ] I like God I like to ride
on the back of a guy's motorcycle like
if you have a motorcycle call pick me up
I like I like that yeah and nothing gets
you more like excited as a girl than
like riding on the back for guys right
you're like straddling him you're
holding his muscles you got the
vibrations going it's a good fun yeah
except the helmets the home it's kind of
a it's down oh yeah but I'd rather have
a helmet on than leg dunk you're in the
elements I mean like I had that I'm like
good like I can scratch it off my list
like I don't need to be on a motorcycle
well I'm just saying occasionally not
like every day he has to take you on a
motorcycle but that's some fun [ __ ] to
do when you get all cute yeah I think
it's fun to get dressed up and get
excited yeah and be taken out and
showing off and you know treated like
the Queen's that we are yeah the Queen
at the county feels good sometimes I
mean like so what'd you do um I go to
comedy clubs yeah what else yeah I guess
so like Monday Monday yeah yeah you're
like alright okay well how do you
usually meet guys it's weird you know
um because I don't do date insights and
stuff so I really feel like I got to
meet my loser face-to-face wherever we
meet you know wait the guy yeah let me
say cornerstone
we're here but I need to see you let me
see you you know I need to feel a
chemistry as well miss [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
this online [ __ ] I'm nervous I tried the
online thing and it hasn't gone very
well for me I mean I've never had a
tinder date or a [ __ ] bumbled a kind
of to known to be on this [ __ ] like you
kind of needa um now maybe yeah I think
that's might be true actually now but
only because people look up my [ __ ] and
then on the day they bring up things
that they already yeah I had a little
success on this one dating app rheya are
you on this one that's for like industry
people that's right you know ruin her so
what you want a waiting list to get into
rape
I actually got right on I got right on
it because I was on it right I got on it
quick I jumped on that jumped on that
ship um I've had some good dates off
there but yeah whatever cuz they
couldn't have been [ __ ] because none of
them you're not with any of them I'm
talking to one and another one I would
have been but this is such a [ __ ] la
small town it's like la is a huge town
but it's such a small town there was a
guy actually went out with on four or
five dates
we hooked up I'm sorry okay for five
times
I don't know date she need to be the
Guinness Book World Record for a [ __ ]
date I don't know okay but they one day
drew it up for dinner or drinks that's
dates right I don't [ __ ] it anyway okay
I went out with him four or five times
we start hooking up great hot good and
bad owns a house got his [ __ ] together
good stuff good all good stuff then I'm
out for coffee with a girlfriend I start
telling her about this guy like I wonder
if you know him his name's dah dah dah
dah dah she's like oh my god I dated him
for four years they were like a couple
for four years I was like are you free
before I knew her so I was like [ __ ] I
can't can't date a guy that you dated
before yet they like live together they
were like together so I had to stop
seeing that guy like immediately I just
stopped returning his tags pretty much I
couldn't I told him well I go I can't
see you anymore I couldn't I could see a
guy on my
and we're we're so weird how long have
you been freeze where I mean only like a
year to be honest but long enough that
and we're gonna close enough that I
couldn't it betraying yeah it was really
what are the odds
yeah but you know if it was meant to be
yeah wouldn't know I was kind of not
feeling it a little bit already I mean
he was into some weird stuff I like
weird fetishes if it feels natural but
if it feels put on I felt like he was
doing it to to like show me that cuz you
know I talk because he knows cuz I talk
on here about what I like and guys here
what I like and you know I go I'll show
her I'm gonna get a sword out my [ __ ]
whip and whip this [ __ ] like it scares
me what did he poo on you know I've
never had that no no I don't do that i
gross Aereo I noted two poos curious let
a guy do video his self pissing on a
stripper I saw in my timeline to send to
you no no you know you're strolling on
no I'm not to sitting to me I don't want
to see the shin I'm like have you ever
had a guy has to pee on you hell no and
if you do what do you think of me into
the guys into peeing on girls
but he's sick ah [ __ ] horses and dogs
humping her peers [ __ ] on someone like
to get off that's like what those
Instagram models that go to like Dubai
and the Arabs take turns [ __ ] on
them like that is like it's like it's
like I hate yeah yeah you know those
Instagram models am I the only one who
knows about this they go to Dubai I get
[ __ ] on they progress to these girls I
thought they just talked protein shake
so okay so the girls who claim to be you
see these girls who are like they have
like a big Instagram following and then
they say that they're models and they're
really pretty with like like
everything's like dawn up you know like
every surgery and then research like you
see their like original face and you're
like [ __ ] oh god you know and then but
so but they're not really models like
you never see them doing like an actual
like photoshoot like you don't see them
do
campaign but they do all these like sexy
photos and then you're like why is this
[ __ ] on a private jet and Dubai like
what what's my like so what it is is
that they're tagged your sponsor like
they're like prostitutes they're
prostitutes and they fly to Dubai and
they get read on yeah and then Arabs
takes her and [ __ ] on them I knew
there's a reason that I should not go
into Instagram modeling besides back in
five five if you like your real scope
Atticus you know I mean I would never
let a guy [ __ ] on me I don't care how in
love I know no no well I mean somebody
who likes you wouldn't [ __ ] on you I
don't know if that's true well I'm only
saying it from her know anyone who's
ventured on like personally I know
people have been peed on I know people
that why did I do it why do they why do
they are they into it that makes them
feel good that gets them hot they're
guys that get off on it I don't know
about the girls I've never met a girl
that's like I love my guys [ __ ] on me
but like you can't have a boner and pee
so that's what's weird to me
well yes you can no you Aaron we need a
guy it's really difficult huh because
the book the blood vessels are all
filled up with what yes that's hard but
you're that day you know but you know
what that's what I was thinking about
too I'm not just social a DVD you know
what it's so easy for guys like if he
had the piece right now he could run
outside yeah and just pull it out it's
hard for us and we have to try to stay
ladylike it rather squatting on these
toilets and do you know how hard it is
to squat sometimes when you're drunk and
you're trying to squat in that piece
shoot down your left thigh and you
Hannah Pompey is addition to save
yourself she's alright [ __ ] pissy
because we don't know which angle
display yeah why did I put like C covers
dad wait we do but kya hai' squat I
would so bad for you I use the seat
covers but here's the thing like five
seat cover right here's the thing so bad
for your vision I know we just had an
election okay and I want to say
something cuz there are a lot of things
on the ballot I'm serious there are a
lot of things on the ballot that are
important and one thing that should be
on the ballot is this do you know
California it's a law that public
restrooms have to have seat covers we
are so blessed here because we go in the
women's room to pee there's a thing
called a toilet seat cover you pull out
of this thing and put on twinsies
and you have to touch your ass to it not
every state has that law when I go home
to Ohio to visit my family almost none
of the bathrooms have them and I miss it
so much I carry them with me yes I just
want to say this should be a national
[ __ ] law that women's room should
advocate old ladies like my grandma do
you know my grandma when I was a kid she
taught me to take the toilet paper
toilet before yeah you know wrong that
takes a little ways which is why when we
hit dress hell Hank you just read a
squat but if your old lady my grandma
can't say why but I'll oh yes the pee
and she has a touch her butt to the seat
and I just send her a seat cover I think
I should send out how does a great
Christmas song look I'm not a trump
supporter but if he gets that done I
might change him hi if you [ __ ] toilet
seat covers in every bathroom in America
that's great that makes you a good kitty
bowl again great again this is great how
did you get kicked out of all we didn't
talk about how you got banned from all
oh yeah has a great ending story this is
good let's not name names I had a fight
let us say the median [ __ ] just a
stupid
you know like nerve wrecking [ __ ] and I
was chillin for two years and I have one
little altercation and now I'm banned
for life I mean it'll be a you guys
getting a fistfight yeah yeah did she
started a band well I mean yeah she
started it by talking to her listen now
we'll be hearing one side to this story
because this comedian is not here but I
will so [ __ ] her but I will say this I
believe you that it wasn't your fault
because I have also had problems with
this [ __ ] every night I know comes to
me with a splashy them why are they not
banning her not banning her I heard she
has performed at the club ah
well because I had to guess I would
guess that maybe she is hooking up with
somebody who can help proud of ya I
don't know here's what I will say okay
cuz it's not funny she's funny
sure she's alright she - she's okay but
like here's the thing she this girl no
this girl precious is like I'm not went
on a date and I don't talk [ __ ] you will
never hear me talk [ __ ] about anybody in
this town I just don't you hear me if
you [ __ ] me man I don't talk shake I
beat her ass and she deserved it you
know I can't tell the story tell me dang
can we bleep that out Aaron oh sorry
[ __ ] that [ __ ] alright forget it well
the point is um I need to near I need to
learn more we're gonna go on to a new
subway but uh the plays I can't go talk
to em dude that's why anybody who used
to see me on video don't see me no more
and we made up since done [ __ ] we have
okay but I still smile when I was there
you know
no childish um hey well on that note and
I'd like someone I can't even pretend
I'll just say what happened isn't that
now I have to tell this story but guys
work we're okay now but um I'm going on
a date showing on a date with a friend
of mine and this was before she knew I
was friends with this person and I
didn't know her very well we'd only met
to two or three times and passing you
know but she's out my friend and he was
new to town and he was just like oh you
do stand-up cool I'm friends with a
couple comedians um do you know this
girl Kate Quigley and she was like oh
you want to be careful with her and he
was like why and she's like well I just
heard she just [ __ ] all the headliners
and he was like oh really and he's like
if she does at me okay it's not and and
uh
gakuen that doesn't work let me figure
out another yeah and then he called and
told me like after that he's like I'm
not gonna go out with her again because
I don't like someone talking [ __ ] about
you and I was really pissed but then
since then um you know she's been
alright she's been nice to me in person
to face but I just open for her uh no I
love it so [ __ ] awkward no sometimes
you just need because people are just
tough when you're not around like I mean
not saying like what were you gonna do
cuz like me I got ignored her for a long
time I don't see the point in
confronting people in this town if
you're not friends it's like I can be
professional I can work with her it's in
my mind I know it happened so what
happened to me is like I had a lot of
things in my mind cuz I know you're I
just know somebody who's just like
telling me all this [ __ ] so I'm able to
see you it's like yeah why don't talk to
me if you got a lot of [ __ ] that I just
don't talk to me don't but talk about a
date fail on her part because this guy
that she went out with my friend is a
very successful wealthy attractive man
and she blew it by talking [ __ ] so
there's a lesson don't talk [ __ ] about
people period I just don't know who
knows who everybody knows everybody why
would you talk [ __ ] about someone on a
date like you know what I mean yeah
secure I'm secure like you hear a
female's name who you know is pretty and
funny and you get insecure see like you
make up some [ __ ] like that's what happy
just to be fair to her I did hook up
with like to headliners she's really
funny every time so I never I never
worked with either one of them I don't
know how about that one how about that
are you looking at with him and getting
nowhere he's like you I mean you're
running in circles homo not even finer
than open my car okay let's keep it real
yo Zen we're we're yet I just like to
say that all things comedy and does not
condone the use of [ __ ] talking or names
associated with this episode of day pals
okay on that no Elan me uh
no you're great you're [ __ ] hilarious
hilarious right yeah we had to go in a
few minutes so um let's do this I always
ask every guest their biggest date fail
what's like the worst thing worst date
ever or maybe the guy with the small
dick was it wasn't any worse than that
that's pretty bad have you had any
recent date fails haven't been on date
and so long I can share one I haven't
shared yet
you know about it was so embarrassing
it's not exactly a date fail but this is
so [ __ ] embarrassing
there's a guy that I used to hook up
with and we kind of started we stopped
talking and we kind of started talking
again and I was like excited to be
talking to him again because we are
great chemistry and so anyway I'm
sitting at home one night and I'm
texting on my laptop because I have this
app where you can text from your laptop
instead of your phone but what sucks
about it is sometimes let's say I'm
texting you and then I'm halfway through
writing an ariel text me her text will
pop up like a pop-up and then I'll go to
reply to her but I might still
accidentally be answering you so I send
a lot of accidental text from this so
I'm texting this guy and then Ariel
texts me something like oh my god I ate
so much today or something I forget what
you said and I replied I replied
haha it's okay it's okay
I'm PMSing I PMSing I ate a bag of chips
and two quest bars for dinner I'm gonna
[ __ ] out a baby and then I hit Send I
was mortified I said it to the guy he
just writes back lol and then I
immediately text I don't know why Sam
Tripoli who's another comic and I go hey
if I say this text should you ever [ __ ]
me again if we were [ __ ] we hadn't
[ __ ] in a while he said it seven he
goes yeah guys have really low standards
you're fine I doubt that it's true man
yeah he's really not that bad is it
do you have one um you know I went on a
date with a guy and he it was like kind
of mediocre and I was already bored and
then he was like I just want you to know
that I accidentally had developed a
crystal meth addiction but I'm okay now
like what what I don't what like I was
like well first of all you're annoying
second like who intentionally develops a
crystal magic
wakes up one morning they're like [ __ ]
my job
I don't need teeth soup is delicious
like what Wow
accidentally that's all and he blamed it
on like his ex-girlfriend I'm like
please stop at least he confessed early
yeah you find that out later that's
heavy
you know yeah but there's something
something was not right like I was like
hmm something's not like I was like
what's wrong like somehow yeah I'd
rather you had a kid denied some [ __ ]
myth
you know I'm saying like let me know
yeah uh it's been an amazing episode
you're a fantastic guest everyone needs
to follow her she's so funny at one
precious comedy it's one the number one
precious comedy precious comedy on
Twitter and Instagram and you got
anything you want to plug coming up you
got it I'm at the J spot Saturday um
8:30
Jenga would ya I love that that's the
first club I ever got paid at really
swear to God
yep yep can you believe that think they
paid me just to come and be like the
white person I was the only white person
all the time early was uh an Ariel
anything you want to promote um on
Sunday I'll be at the haha at the 8 p.m.
show and open space at the that 10 p.m.
show
cool ish good stuff she thinks followers
on social media and follow me @kq funny
follow at iranian mermaid or at Ariel's
not a mermaid
on Instagram and follow all things
comedy there's lots of good shows on
this network you guys are the best and
we'll be back next time bye
[Music]